jetzt aber mal was heiteres meine Damen
und Herren der Untergang der
us-demokratie und damit der gesamten
westlichen Welt ist zumindest
aufgeschoben zur Erinnerung fast alle
Experten hatten bei den sogenannten mit
terms am Dienstag mit einem Triumph der
Republikaner gerechnet also der
durchgeknallten Trump Pisten sag mal
glaube ich und stell dir vor exakt so
ist es nicht gekommen ja eigentlich darf
man gar keine Umfragen mehr lesen da ist
die rote Welle ausgeblieben die große
rote Welle eine rote Welle große rote
Welle eine rote Welle von einem roten
Tsunami jetzt ist es maximal eine rote
Pfütze
[Applaus]
ja die Republikaner und die Pfütze des
Grauens im Repräsentanten Haus holen sie
sehr wahrscheinlich die Mehrheit aber im
Senat sieht es momentan nach einem
Unentschieden aus falls Sie da mal
irgendwann fertig werden mit zählen
Amerikaner können alles mögliche aber
Stimmen zählen ist einfach nicht ihr
Ding das dauert Wahnsinn und was heißt
das jetzt für Donald Trump tja etliche
seiner durchgeknallten Kandidaten sind
kläglich gescheitert Martin das jetzt
vielleicht nachdenklich der war gut
[Musik]
natürlich was ich immer sage dumm sein
macht glücklich
anonyme Quellen berichten Trump habe am
Dienstag stundenlang wütend und pöbelnd
vor seinem Fernseher gesessen ja und das
ist verständlich
das muss man verstehen sogar Fox News
wendet sich ab von dem Mann dabei hat er
doch den Fans für nächste Woche eine
Zitat sehr große Ankündigung versprochen
was könnte das sein ich drehe durch
Verspannung gibt da nicht zu das ist
doch eine Perücke ist bitte bitte achso
er tritt 2024 wieder an lame
ich verspreche euch in der sehr sehr nah
an Zukunft werde ich euch glücklich
machen
oh Gott
sehr sehr glücklich machen würdest du
uns wenn du endlich in den Knast gehst
ja die Anhörung zum Putschversuch vom 6
Januar 21 beweisen dass Trump da eben
nicht nur Zuschauer war warum darf der
trotzdem noch mal antreten dieser elende
frisurensohn warum warum
wenn er denn antritt wenn denn für seine
Republikaner hat sich ja diese Woche
eine echte Alternative aufgetan ronde
Säntis goover näher von Florida
Spitzname Trump with the brain
wirklich Trump aber mit Gehirn ist ein
absoluter Albtraum brandgefährlich the
Cent ist hat in Florida einen
Erdrutschsieg hingelegt und seine
Wahlspots sind
recht selbstbewusst
schon
der nächste Geist ist Kranke sehr schön
mein Gott was wird das für ein Showdown
der Säntis gegen Trump also einer der
sich für einen Gesandten Gottes hält
gegen einen der sich für Gott hält das
wird so spannend meine Damen und Herren
das wird richtig spannend
und das wird auch garantiert schmutzig
das wird schmutzig dafür sorgt schon
Elon Musk der neue Gott bei Twitter ja
ab jetzt darf nämlich wieder jeder alles
sagen auf Twitter der nächste
Präsidentschaftswahlkampf in den USA
wird der härteste aller Zeiten totale
Meinungsfreiheit total also
außer natürlich wenn man Elon Musk
kritisiert dann wird man rausgeschmissen
wie das ZDF damals bei Tesla an seinem
ersten Arbeitstag bei Twitter ist Elon
mit einem Waschbecken ins Büro geladen
auf Englisch sink nur im twittern zu
können let that sync in kille kille
Wortspiele die körperlich weh tun würden
wir nie machen
ja dann hat er erstmal die Hälfte der
Twitter Belegschaft gefeuert nur um drei
Sekunden später zu merken dass er einige
davon noch braucht
ja komm ist uns allen schon passiert ich
habe zum Beispiel am Montag alle meine
Grafiker gefeuert denn mal ehrlich das
kann ich doch auch selber okay ist doch
kein großes Ding ja wo ist das Problem
wo ist das Problem Elon Musk dem
reichsten Mann der Welt gehört jetzt
also auch noch Twitter mit 240 Millionen
Usern weltweit plus eigene Raketen und
eigene Satelliten mask ist wirklich ja
sowas wie die Kreuzung aller bekannten
James Bond Schurken in einer Person
demnächst im Kino der Milliardär der
sich liebte ja
nicht gucken ist ein ganz schlimmer Film
da gibt es unter anderem eine fünf
Minuten Szene wo sich Elon Musk selber
einen bläst ich würde es nicht gucken
wirklich
hallo Leute Ich bin's der heute-show
Mime Ersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen
Scheiß und Lied
memes wollt dann abonniert jetzt den
Kanal
was zur Hölle ist ein meme Ersteller
[Musik]